bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue à
cette soirée débat qui va débuter dans
quelques instants le temps que tout le
monde nous rejoigne merci d'avoir
répondu présent présente le nombre de
participants ne fait que augmenté alors
n'hésitez pas comme certains l'ont déjà
fait à vous exprimer au travers du chat
youtube qui se trouva à la droite de
votre écran vous pouvez nous dire par
exemple depuis calvet le vous nous
suivez et vous pourrez également tout au
long de ce live poser les questions que
vous souhaiteriez
posées aux invités et nous y serons
ensuite d'y répondre à la fin de cette
rencontre en tout cas soyez les
bienvenus
le thème de cette soirée comme cela est
écrit à l'écran est le suivant dans un
monde qui se croient sans limite comment
rendre acceptable la sobriété
énergétique
en effet l'urgence est là et le dernier
rapport du groupe numéro trois du giec
le groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat vous alerté il
ya quelques semaines que les prochaines
années seront décisives pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique de notre
planète la transformation de notre
modèle économique et énergétique devient
une priorité absolue dans ce contexte
comment sensibiliser et encourager nos
concitoyens à changer leur mode de vie
nous inviter vont tenter d'y répondre
d'ici quelques minutes
alors cette soirée débat elle est
organisée par le forum veritas qui est
une initiative proposée par les groupes
bibliques universitaires de france les
gpu qui constitue une association
culturelle qui réunit des étudiants pour
réfléchir autour de la bible et 2 sont
l'enseignement
cette soirée débat est également
organisée en partenariat avec arusha une
organisation chrétienne qui oeuvre pour
la protection de la nature
immobile les chrétiens autour de la
crise écologique
les forums veritas enfin sont des
rencontres qui visent à mettre en
dialogue la pensée chrétienne avec
d'autres visions du monde et à ce titre
nous avons été sensible et attentif à la
volonté exprimée par l'un de nos invités
ce soir jean marc jancovici qui
souhaitait dialoguer avec acteurs issus
de la sphère religieuse ce qui m'a
confié lors d'un récent entretien avec
la chaîne youtube fine kirby alors note
si notre seconde invité jean louis jean
françois moreau n'a pas la prétention de
représenter toutes les religions ce soir
il tentera en tout cas de porter la voix
d'un nombre croissant de chrétiens qui
sont désireux de voir les enjeux
écologiques pris au sérieux dans leur
communauté je me présente je m'appelle
joseph quote je suis doctorant en
communication politique à l'université
paris est créteil et jamie murray ce
soir cette discussion entre deux
orateurs des qualités qui pourront nous
apporter leurs éléments de réflexion sur
un sujet actuel est brûlant sens
littéral comme figuré
alors le premier invité que nous
accueillons et jean françois moreau bien
bonjour et bienvenue
jean-françois mots vous êtes docteur en
histoire conférencier et directeur da
rocha france vous avez enseigné
notamment à l'université de georgetown à
washington à l'université de birmingham
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
dont des esclaves énergétique réflexion
sur le changement climatique dans lequel
vous fait un parallèle entre notre
difficulté actuelle à décarbonés la la
société et celle des sociétés
esclavagistes du 18ème et 19ème siècles
abolir l'esclavagé
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
notre second intervenant et jean marc
jancovici
bonjour et bienvenue jean marc jancovici
vous êtes ingénieur de l'école bonne
technique consultant et spécialiste de
l'énergie du climat vous êtes également
conférencier membre du haut conseil pour
le climat auprès du nouveau premier
ministre
professeur à l'école des mines et auteur
de livres à succès dont votre bande
dessinée pédagogique le monde sans faim
miracles énergétiques et des riffs
climatique que vous avez écrit avec
christophe blain qui a été publié en
2020 et qui rencontre un franc succès
puisqu'il a été déjà écoulé à plus de
deux cent cinquante mille exemplaires et
qu'il figure parmi les livres les plus
vendus en ce début d'année 2022 connu
pour votre travail de sensibilisation et
de vulgarisation sur les thèmes de
l'énergie et du réchauffement climatique
vous êtes co fondateur et associé de là
société de conseil carbone 4 ainsi que
président fondateur du groupe de
réflexion the shift project et enfin
certains de nos éditeurs l'ont peut-être
remarqué mais votre nom est fréquemment
cité dans la presse et les médias ces
derniers jours comme potentiel futur
ministre de la planification écologique
ou de l'énergie peut-être que vous
souhaiterez réagir ensuite à cela merci
en tout cas d'avoir répondu présent
malgré on imagine des nombreuses
sollicitations qui sont les vôtres
voici le déroulé de la soirée donc nous
allons avoir principalement trois temps
un premier temps vous nous donnera la
parole à chaque intervenant durant une
vingtaine de minutes pour que vous
puissiez exprimer votre propos sur scène
sur cette question ensuite suivra un
temps d'échangé entre vous deux d'une
quinzaine de minutes et enfin nous
conclurons avec une demi heure de
questions
répondez par rapport aux interrogations
pire ont été formulées par nos
internautes je vous invite dès
maintenant à les poser vos questions
dans le chatt youtube et sans plus
attendre je donne la parole à jean
françois mourgues pour une première
intervention de la soirée sur le thème
dans un monde qui se croient sans limite
comment rendre acceptable la sobriété
énergétique
merci beaucoup joseph et merci beaucoup
jean-marc je suis très honoré d'avoir la
chance de pouvoir dialoguer avec toi ce
soir de ce sujet qui me passionne depuis
tant d'années et je voudrais d'abord te
remercier en fait parce que si je suis
là ce soir c'est en grande partie grâce
à toi d'abord parce que c'est en lisant
ton livre le plein si groupés en 2006
alors ça commence à remonter un petit
peu que j'ai vraiment pris conscience de
la gravité du défi qui était devant nous
au de gravité de la crise énergétique et
climatique et ça m'a décidé à réorienter
complètement ma vie professionnelle pour
me trouver finalement aujourd'hui ce
soir à discuter de ces sujets avec toi
et un autre truc que tu fais peut-être
tel musée et que je pense pas avoir déjà
dit c'est que la lecture de ton livre va
aussi ramener curieusement à la fois
parce que j'avais
grandi et j'avais quitté la fois dans
laquelle j'avais grandi avec mes parents
et mes en lisant son livre je me suis
dit là on est face à en fait un problème
est tel que j'ai eu la conviction que
l'on pourrait pas s'en sortir tout seul
alors ça c'est peut-être un effet
secondaire que tu n'anticipait pas de
ton livre mais en tout cas voilà l'effet
que ça eu sur moi alors d'abord je
voudrais commencer par définir de quoi
on parle ce soir
eh ben on parle de l'énergie bien sûr
alors ta propre définition l'énergie
c'est ce qui constitue ce qui quantifie
la transformation de l'environnement
alors je vous renvoie à tout et nombreux
ouvrages et
publications et interviews sur youtube
pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus
la sobriété dans ce contexte c'est la
modération et l'acceptation des limites
et notamment l'acceptation de réduire sa
consommation d'énergie et est donc notre
consommation de ressources plus
généralement
j'ajoute que tu définit aussi la
sobriété d'une autre manière un peu plus
lapidaire étudie la sobriété c'est quand
on choisit volontairement et quand on
choisit pas c'est ce qu'on peut appeler
la pauvreté donc la sobriété ont choisi
de se serrer la ceinture la pauvreté
c'est quand on choisit alors d'abord on
pourrait se poser la question pourquoi
est ce qu'il faut être sobre alors j'ai
pas expliqué si dans le détail pourquoi
on a besoin d'aller vers la sobriété
énergétique là encore les nombreux des
nombreuses personnes qui le suivent
savent très bien tout ce que tu dis sur
le sujet depuis très longtemps
c'est dû pour faire simple aléa compte
double contrainte énergie et climat
voilà il ya une nouveauté importante à
propos de la sobriété et il me semble
c'est que le dernier rapport du giec et
dont on a parlé en introduction
qui avait paru donc il ya un mois
consacre pour la première fois un
chapitre de son rapport donc à la
nécessité de réduire notre demande
d'énergie et d'adopter des comportements
plus sobres et ça c'est relativement
nouveau parce que l'idée jusque là était
assez répandue que on allait pouvoir
nous sortir de cette impasse dans lequel
on se trouvait qu'on allait pouvoir
effectuer cette transition sans avoir
réellement besoin de réduire notre
consommation juste en développant des
énergies entre guillemets propres
et la france est concernée par ce fait
appelle à la sobriété puisqu'elle s'est
fixé comme la plupart des pays du monde
aujourd'hui des objectifs de réduction
des émissions de co2 et si le giec nous
dit que ces émissions vont passer
forcément par une réduction de la
demande ça nous oblige à réfléchir à la
sobriété alors le chiffre project que tu
diriges ae a publié il ya deux mois un
plan de transformation de l'économie
française dont l'objectif est de
décarbonés la france tout en préservant
l'emploi et tu montre toi aussi à
travers ce livre en tout cas votre
équipe que ça passe nécessairement par
une diminution de la consommation
mais si ce plan offre une feuille de
route sur comment être sobre sobre avec
des objectifs chiffrés etc ils laissent
ils me sens largement de côté la
question de l'acceptabilité tu ne parles
brièvement de ce sujet qu'à la toute fin
du livre en écrivant que tu as tenté de
dessiner un plan non seulement
acceptable mais aussi désirable mais les
journalistes du monde par exemple qui
ont recensé ouvrages ont relevé que
rendre désirable ce plan c'est
probablement la mission la plus
difficile et c'est ce que reconnaissait
aussi fabrice bonnifet administrateur du
chiffre que tu connais bien et depuis
longtemps qui déclarait lui aussi
récemment que rendre la sobriété
désirable représentent le défi ultime de
l'humanité
et c'est précisément ce point sur lequel
aujourd'hui le monde entier but qui me
semble et c'est exactement le sujet du
débat de ce soir alors j'ajoute que
évidemment c'est aussi une question de
riches parce que a peut-être qu'un jour
peut-être demain on se posera plus cette
question si d'aventuré la guerre en
ukraine où d'autres crises qui pourrait
tout à fait se dérouler comme tu le dis
depuis bien longtemps pourrait couper
notre approvisionnement en pétrole en
gaz et en charbon
mais pour le moment on est obligé de se
poser cette question
et pour poser autrement la question en
termes plus concrets qu'est ce que tu
fais si demain on te propose et que tu
acceptes bien sûr un poste de ministre
de la transition écologique tu vas te
retrouver face à des tas d'opposition au
plan de la trempe de transformation
l'économie française et comment tu feras
pour que les français et les françaises
se suivent alors que tu dis toi même
avec eux à juste titre à mon avis que la
plupart des gens ne comprennent pas
vraiment les enjeux et confondent
entendre parler du problème avec bien
comprendre
alors pour aborder cette question de
comment rendre acceptable ou désiré
cette sobriété j'ai commencé par passer
rapidement en revue les arguments que
j'ai repéré dans tes discours notamment
et dans ce quelques autres aussi
avant d'expliquer en quoi ces arguments
ne paraisse trop limité et proposé
d'autres pistes à explorer
alors il me semble que tu utilises trois
grands types d'arguments rationnels pour
expliquer pourquoi on devrait adopter un
mode de vie plus sobres le premier c'est
que il est préférable de choisir la
sobriété plutôt que de la subir c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il est donc
de notre intérêt d'éviter les pires
effets du changement climatique ou
d'éviter d'attendre qu'ils aient plus
d'essence à la pompe le deuxième
argument
c'est qu'il ya plein de kobe néfice à
adopter un mode de vie plus sobres pour
la santé pour l'économie pour la justice
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
sobriété heureuse qu'on pourrait résumer
par la formule moins de biens plus de
liens moins de biens matériels plus de
liens sociaux affectifs par exemple
prend le vélo ou aller à pied plutôt de
prendre sa voiture mieux isoler les
logements manger moins de viande ont des
tas de bénéfices secondaires
on libère du temps on libère d'autre
chose qui nous permette de on libère
voilà du temps pour faire d'autres
choses qui sont plus importants comme
vivre aimer
ralentir
troisième argument qu'il me semble utile
ghz et tu pourras bien sûr compléter et
ou corriger ce que je dis
le troisième argument c'est que
mobilisés nous mobiliser sur ces
questions ça donne du travail ça éloigne
de nous l'oise yves t comme dirait
voltaire et ça donne du sens à nos vies
et à titre perso effectivement c'est ça
qui m'a encouragé à changer de métier
parce que je veux pas que sur mon lit de
mort mes enfants me disent papa qu'est
ce que tu as fais toi pour essayer de
stopper le changement climatique
alors pour autant ces trois arguments
qui me semble tout à fait pertinent
trouve à mon avis leur limite assez
rapidement d'abord comme tu le reconnais
bien toi même je te cite nous ne sommes
pas des animaux rationnelle et se sont
toujours in fine et nos envies et nos
désirs qui ont le dernier mot fin de
citation ça c'est dans le plan de
transformation l'économie française et
de fait ça fait 2 120 ans qu'on comprend
les mécanismes de l'effet de serre ça
fait au moins cinquante ans des
scientifiques nous met en garde chaque
jour de manière plus forte sur le
problème il y à des jeunes 26 conférence
internationale sur le climat les
fameuses coop et pas mal de plans de
restructuration de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
pas mal de pays et pourtant les
émissions globales continuent à
augmenter en ligne droite comme tu le
dit d'ailleurs de manière très
humoristique dans un thé graphique dans
sa conférence à sciences po
et il y a encore énormément de freins
qui font que plein de personne ne
souhaite pas réduire leur consommation
soit parce qu'ils sont plus préoccupés
par leur fin de mois que par la fin du
monde selon la formule désormais
consacrée
soit parce qu'ils ignorent où ni la
gravité du problème soit parce qu'au
contraire ils sont convaincus que c'est
trop tard pour agir ou alors qu'ils ne
savent pas par où commencer le problème
paraît tellement énorme soit parce
qu'ils ne voient pas pourquoi ils se
serraient la ceinture alors que les
chinois ou les américains ne semblent
pas le faire soit parce qu'ils ont perdu
toute confiance dans le gouvernement ou
dans les médias
soit parce qu'ils continuent à croire
que la technologie va nous sauver soit
parce qu'ils ont des intérêts
économiques au statu quo j'en passe et
des meilleurs on voit que cette question
est difficile quand par exemple on
tergiverse quand il est question de
réduire notre consommation de gaz pour
mettre la pression à poutine et
potentiellement sauver des vies en
ukraine
j'ajoute que je crois qu'on est devant
une situation qui est sans doute aussi
difficile que celle de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
il ya deux siècles en fait même
peut-être plus difficile parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'exemple historique de sociétés
esclavagistes ayant aboli l esclavage
sans pression extérieure et parce que
dans le cas de l' esclavage on a pu
remplacer les esclaves en chair et en os
par des machines et fameuse esclaves
énergétique je te renvoie à mon livre
sur le sujet certes il ya une différence
importante bien sûr puisque jamais des
sociétés esclavagistes non menacées par
leur mode de vie de détruire le climat
la planète et on peut espérer que ce
dernier facteur engendre une plus forte
mobilisation pour le climat que contre
l' esclavage dans les sociétés
esclavagistes
mais ça ne change pas le fait que je ne
suis pas très optimiste sur le niveau
d'acceptabilité du plan de
transformation n'est que de doter
l'économie française s'ils devaient être
mis en oeuvre demain ce qui
n'empêcherait pas évidemment de le
soutenir de toutes mes forces
il me semble en fait qu'on bute sur un
problème majeur de dissonance cognitive
que tu met bien en avant dans ta formule
lapidaire co2 ou pib il faut choisir
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas en même
temps avoir la croissance est moins de
co2
or nos sociétés soit addict à la
croissance nos politiques les médias et
les gens de la rue ont la conviction que
sans croissance on est voué à voir le
chômage et les problèmes augmenté et il
suffisait d'écouter la radio ou la télé
la semaine dernière quand les chiffres
de la croissance française et américaine
ont été révélés pour le dernier
trimestre et que ça a déclenché beaucoup
de réactions plus ou moins paniqués dans
les médias parce qu'il n'était pas entre
guillemets bon
en fait on est abreuvé dès la naissance
par un discours hégémonique la
croissance est bonne selon ce discours
le progrès est bon et dans un monde
matérialiste
on nous laisse croire effectivement que
le bonheur vient de notre consommation
de la technique c'est ce que la
publicité notamment nous martèle eu
constamment plus on a un gros suv ou le
dernier sac à main hermès et plus on est
censé être heureux alors bien évidemment
beaucoup de gens ont conscience de la
supercherie mais il est très difficile
dans une société qui se limite au monde
matériel de proposer d'autres horizons
d'attenté
j'ajoute que même si le plan de
transformation de la de l'économie
française devenait désirable c'est pas
pour cela qu'ils seraient forcément mise
en oeuvre pour la même raison que plein
de gens prennent de bonnes résolutions
comme celle par exemple de faire des
régimes mais on sait très bien que très
peu de personnes tiennent leurs
engagements surtout sur le long terme et
surtout quand on est entouré de
publicité de vendeurs de frites de
chocolat et de cela on est dans une
situation un peu comparable actuellement
à celles de quelqu'un voulant faire un
régime tout en étant enfermé dans une
pâtisserie avec crédit illimité
donc même si les raisons que tu donnes
pour inciter à la sobriété me paraissent
tout à fait valable d'un point de vue
rationnel je crains qu'elle ne soit pas
suffisante pour rendre désirable la
sobriété ni a fortiori pour mettre en
oeuvre son plan je voudrais toutefois
proposé d'autres pistes pour rendre plus
désirable et mettre en oeuvre et de
sobriété et je passe donc à ma deuxième
partie
un conseiller d'obama a dit ceci il y a
quelques années j'ai longtemps pensé que
les principaux problèmes
environnementaux était la perte de
biodiversité et le changement climatique
je pensais que trente ans de bonne
science pouvait résoudre ces problèmes
j'avais tort les principaux problèmes
environnementaux sont l'égoïsme la
cupidité et l'apathie et pour y faire
face nous avons besoin d'une
transformation culturelle et spirituelle
et nous les scientifiques nous ne savons
pas comment faire
toi même dans ta bd un monde sans faim
tu expliques les comportements
irrationnels de l'homme par le fait
qu'on est façonnée par notre génétique
et notre striatum c'est à dire une
partie de notre cerveau qui cherche
notre plaisir immédiat sans trop se
préoccuper des conséquences
mais l'égoïsme la recherche du plaisir
dictée par le striatum c'est tout
simplement ce que la bible appelle le
péché c'est un mot qui désigne au départ
simplement le fait de rater la cible
alors là où la physique peut-être ne
peut plus nous aider la métaphysique
peut peut-être nous donner un coup de
pouce déterminant je pense en effet que
l'habile et la foi chrétienne peuvent
d'une part aider au diagnostic sur les
raisons du problème
proposez aussi une voix celle du
contentement qui est un recentrement sur
quelque chose d'autre que le
matérialisme proposait aussi un remède
contre le désespoir paralysant à
condition de ne pas en faire une
échappatoire à nos responsabilités et de
manière pratique l'église s'est aussi
beaucoup de petits soldats potentiel
pour la lutte contre le changement
climatique
alors d'abord je pense que le problème
de la sobriété comme on l'a dit est un
problème au moins en partie spirituelle
et ça fait quand même trois mille ans
que la bible parle de ses problèmes et
propose un chemin pour essayer de s'en
sortir et il serait dommage à mon sens
de se priver de cette sagesse
pourrait donner je pourrais développer
sa très longue mais pour faire court on
pourrait dire que les deux principaux
commandements de la bible sont d'aimer
dieu et son prochain c'est bien son
voisin or on peut pas répondre à ce
commandement il me semble sans
nécessairement souhaitait diminuer son
empreinte écologique
la bible mais aussi en garde contre le
désir mimétique c'est à dire le fait de
désirer ce qui appartient aux autres ça
c'est le dixième commandement et ensuite
parce que le problème du changement
climatique est fondamentalement un
problème d' injustice et que là encore
la bible mais constamment en garde sur
la nécessité de pratiquer la justice au
risque de graves désordres de la société
c'est le fameux dicton pape paix sont
juste les chrétiens devraient donc être
naturellement déjà très sensible à ces
questions si on arrive à trouver le bon
bouton
pour être continue en disant qu'il ya
des incitations à un mode de vie simple
à presque chaque page de la bible
d'abord parce que les chrétiens se
veulent des disciples du christ et que
ce dernier a toute sa vie était un
exemple de huit simples il est né dans
une étable je le rappelle entouré de
pauvres de marginaux dans ses discours
aussi il n'a cessé de répéter heureux
les pauvres ne vous attachez pas aux
richesses du monde on ne peut servir
dieu et l'argent gardez-vous de
l'avarice etc les apôtres aussi on
continue à promouvoir plutôt que la
sobriété le contentement montrant qu'on
peut être content avec ce conte à 100
des hydres est toujours plus prends un
exemple parmi des dizaines d'autres ne
vous livrez pas à l'amour de l'argent
contentez vous de ce que vous avez dit
l'épître aux hébreux alors bien sûr aux
cours d'histoire il ya eu plein de
dérive plein de chrétiens qui sont
devenus riches et qui ce faisant ont
souvent perdu la foi mais ces dérives
ont été aussi ponctuée par des réveils
comme au temps de françois des 6 ou pour
prendre des exemples plus récent martin
luther king l'abbé pierre ou mère teresa
bref la bible et l'histoire des
chrétiens offre tout à la fois des
exemples et des commandements précis en
faveur du contentement de la non
puissance termes que j'emprunte un
penseur protestants qui s'appelle et
jacques ellul et d'un mode de vie simple
et ont pu s'appuyer sur cette sagesse
pour progresser
la foi chrétienne aussi offre quelques
avantages par rapport à la seule
physique et là tu dira peut-être que je
triche mais c'est bien utile dans un
monde qui désespère le premier première
à tous qu'on peut avoir
que tu réfutera peut-être mais c'est
d'abord la promesse de jésus des trains
aux côtés quand on affronte les
difficultés de la vie il nous a dit vous
êtes je serai avec vous tous les jours
jusqu'à la fin du monde ou celle de la
baie de l'apôtre paul qui affirme que
rien ni aucune épreuve ne pourrons nous
séparer de l'amour de dieu
les chrétiens donc la conviction de ne
pas être seul dans ce combat et ça aide
c'est un peu comme quand on joue au
football à domicile et qu'on allait
supporter qui nous soutiennent même si
on ne croit pas à la puissance du
saint-esprit on peut constater que
ça peut aider d'avoir de la force
mentale
la foi chrétienne offre offre aussi une
promesse de récompense dans cette ville
après la mort à ceux qui pratiquent la
justice et à d'autres un mode de vie
simple
alors là encore on pourrait multiplier
les exemples jésus qui a dit ne vous
amassez pas des trésors sur la terre ou
la teigne et la rouille détruisent et où
les voleurs terre c'est des robes mais
amassé vous des trésors dans le ciel
autrement dit ceux qui pratiquent la
justice dans ce monde seront récompensés
par dieu alors c'est évidemment les
marxistes ont beaucoup reproché aux
chrétiens le mal qu'on peut faire à
partir de ce genre de de raisonnement
mais je pense que si c'est bien utiliser
ça peut être un outil fort aussi pour de
mobilisation et de de confiance nous
croyons que prendre soin des pauvres
lutter contre l'injustice climatique et
contre l'effondrement de la biodiversité
plaît à dieu et qu'il ya une récompense
pour ceux qui s'affichent qui s'attache
à ce combat et nous croyons aussi que la
terre sera ultime en restaurer dans
toute sa richesse débarrasser du
problème du changement climatique
et cette espérance aussi nous a aidé à
tenir le coup
alors je disais aussi que dernier point
c'est que l'église c'est quand même
beaucoup de petits soldats qui peuvent
être mobilisés on a près de deux
milliards et demi de personnes qui se
déclarent chrétiens dans le monde
l'église est la plus grande ong du monde
et si on arrive à mobiliser ne serait ce
que 10 % des effectifs pour prendre au
sérieux la crise climatique et mobiliser
les gens sur cette question on en a déjà
une force de pression considère un
bailleur qui tu remarques avec
l'obligation que nous allons avoir de
renoncer bientôt à notre costume d'iron
man pour reprendre la métaphore dans un
monde sans fin il est fort à parier que
beaucoup de gens vont retourner à des
formes de spiritualité
l'athéisme en effet une spécificité de
nos sociétés modernes l'immense majorité
des personnes dans le monde avant la fin
du xviiie siècle et encore aujourd'hui
sont religieuses ou était religieuse
d'une manière ou d'une autre et on
observe ayant un grand autour de
spiritualité sous différentes formes
en france les églises protestantes et
catholiques et la forme d'un grand
réseau dans absolument tout le
territoire ça aussi ça peut être utile
pour mobiliser et peut agir localement
il ya des actions de mobilisation et de
sensibilisation comme le label et glisse
vers tous les réseaux d'ambassadeurs ou
des groupes locaux développé par
l'association arche à les églises
peuvent encore aussi avoir pas mal
d'influx ans à la société avec la
possibilité de mobiliser les ressources
financières avec des fidèles qui donne
en moyenne plus pour différentes causes
que la moyenne nationale et qui
s'engagent plus dans la société c'est
d'ailleurs en reconnaissance à que
nicolas hulot avant la côte 21 avait
fait l'appel aux églises pour provoquer
je cite un sursaut de conscience face à
la crise climatique
bien sûr cette mobilisation ne pourra se
faire que si l'église au sens de la
communauté des croyants pour peut faire
son aggiornamento c'est-à-dire qu'elle
reconnaît qu'elle a fait fausse route
comme une grande partie de l'humanité en
idolâtrant la croissance et en étant
contaminée par l'évangile de la
prospérité qui prétend que les ans mais
financière des chrétiens est un signe de
santé spirituelle et que la pauvreté est
une malédiction et bien sûr les choses
bougent là dessus on a eu l'encyclique
que lahoud at sea du pape en 2015 et du
côté protestant aussi ça avance je vais
pas développer cette partie là mais
juste en concluant cette partie pour
dire que dans cette course contre la
montre dans cette lutte pour la
mobilisation citoyenne sur le climat les
églises et des chrétiens peuvent donc
jouer un rôle non négligeable
s'ils se saisissent véritablement des
enjeux et puis un combat qui est au
moins en partie spirituelle doit être
mené aussi avec des armes spirituelles
je crois à la puissance de la prière et
je prie pour que dieu nous sortent du
pétrin dans lequel nous sommes coincés
tout ça pour dire quoi et je conclus je
rassure joseph qui commence à avoir peur
et peut-être toi aussi je crois j'espère
que tu vas recevoir ce coup de fil des
menus et le maquereau dans les prochains
jours pour te proposer le poste de
ministre de la transition énergétique ou
pourquoi pas de premier ministre
ça me fait penser à 4 2 elle m'a raconté
dans le livre la genèse de la genèse
joseph qui était un esclave hébreu
explique aux pharaons qui va y avoir des
années de vaches maigres à l'horizon et
lui présente un plan pour sauver
l'egypte de la famine le pharaon le
nomme alors premier ministre avec pour
mission de mettre en oeuvre son plan
alors si tu reçois ce coup de fil
j'espère qu'il est que si emmanuel
macron te donne suffisamment de marge de
manoeuvre est garanti et un gros budget
que tu dira oui si tu arrives à mettre
en oeuvre son plan de transformation de
l'économie française notre pays aura
fait un immense pas en avant et si tu
arrives pas au moins tu auras essayé tu
seras pas le premier à te frotter au
ministère de l'impossible mais je veux
croire que ça fera quand même avancer
les choses alors si tu est nommé à ce
poste n'oublie pas le rôle que peuvent
jouer les hommes et les femmes de foi
pour aider à mobiliser sur ces questions
et moi personnellement je me réjouis de
voir enfin un ministre arrivé en rer et
en vélo au ministère merci
merci jean françois moureau pour cette
belle entrée en matière et votre
perspective de chrétiens sur le sujet
alors vous avez formulé un certain
nombre d'interpellations vis-à-vis de
jean marc jancovici et sans plus
attendre je lui laisse la parole
et affectivement content d'avoir
l'occasion de discuter avec un monde que
je confesse peut connaître
j'ai dû mettre les pieds dans un lieu de
culte je sais pas 10 fois dans ma vie ou
15 fois dans leur vie enfin je parle pas
des quelques fois où j'ai visité les
cathédrales dans
en espagne ou en france mais
c'est je confesse très c'est le motif
constance très simplement de ne pas y
aller très souvent
cela étant j'ai trouvé je trouve
extrêmement intéressant le propos de
jean-françois
parce que je le rejoins sur quelque
chose d'absolument fondamentale qui est
absolument pas le fait que je sois
appelé pour devenir ministre donc ça je
peux tout de suite faire la même réponse
que j'ai fait jusqu'à maintenant
qui est que ça n'entre pas vraiment dans
les plans pour l'avenir pour le moment
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
lui sur le fait qu'un projet de société
c'est par avant tout des lycées des
boulons c'est avant tout du désir c'est
avant tout une communion c'est avant
tout quelque chose de non non marchand
ça repose avant tout sur les valeurs et
donc ce sur quoi les religieux enfin ce
que les religieux pourrait appeler de la
spiritualité
il ya un mathématicien des amis qui
avaient dit leur ekland
qui est un des fondateurs de paris
dauphine et qui a dit un jour jamais on
ne résoudra le problème du changement
climatique tant qu'on en fait un
problème économique il faut que ça
devienne un problème éthique il faut
donc que ça devienne un problème moral
et quand on parle d'éthique et de morale
il me semble qu'on est très très près de
la religion après il reste plus qu'à se
mettre d'accord sur qui ou quoi et dieu
mais au fond ça n'est que le point de
détail qui nous restent à régler
une fois qu'on est d'accord sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire que le projet
de société c'est avant tout quelque
chose qui est un élan collectif autour
de valeurs partagées
donc j'ai dit effectivement un certain
nombre de fois dit répété que je ne
croyais pas une seconde que l'on
pourrait mettre en oeuvre le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
comme ça en fait si je suis un tout
petit peu plus précis ce plan je crois
qu'on ne le mettra malheureusement en
oeuvre qu'à l'occasion d'une crise et
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une crise
finalement c'est un brutal changement de
paradigme c'est un moment où on se rend
compte que quelque chose qu'on tenait
pour acquis ou pour important hier
devient moins acquis ou important demain
et donc il faut faire passer devant
autre chose qui devient tout d'un coup
plus important par exemple si tout d'un
coup il ya plus d'essence dans les
stations-service et bien on retrouvera
immédiatement quelque chose qui
s'appelle de la solidarité donc les gens
vont gueuler ça va respecter et on a
souffrances et ses meilleurs a
instantanément de l'entr'aide donc le
label la question c'est une valeur
nouvelle qui apparaît tout d'un coup
parce que le contexte change donc je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec
jean-françois sur le fait que ce plan
aucune chance d'advenir dans un monde
calme
par contre la raison pour laquelle on
l'a fait c'est qu'on pense qu'il peut
servir de pense-bête utile dans un monde
où tout d'un coup le paradigme me
changerait tout simplement parce que là
il ya un imprévu qui fait qu'on est bien
obligé de changer la manière de changer
notre rapport au monde de changer la
façon dont les choses se passent je me
suis fait la réflexion pas plus tard que
cet après midi enfin genre il à faire
avant et elle est facile à faire que
d'ici à 2050 c'est-à-dire l'année où
normalement selon les plans européens et
selon les grandes déclarations de droite
et de gauche il faudrait que nous ayons
atteint la neutralité carbone chose qui
est nécessaire si on veut limiter le
réchauffement climatique sous quelque
chose qui se promène entre 1,5 et 2
degrés est bas d'ici à 2050 il nous
reste cinq mandats présidentiels plein à
supposer qu'on soit toujours en
démocratie on devait 50 en incluant
celui qui démarre maintenant c'est à
dire que il y aura cinq fois à supposer
encore une fois qu'on reste en
démocratie qu'on reste dans un univers
calme ce qui est pas du tout gagné
d'avancé
nous aurons cinq élections
présidentielles d'ici à 2050 c'est pas
beaucoup 1,5 ça se compte sur les doigts
d'une main sauf erreur de ma part donc
c'est vraiment un temps un temps de la
cour
et donc pour en revenir à la où propos
de ce soir qui est quid de la religion
dans cette affaire je reste persuadé que
effectivement sur un temps aussi court
on ne peut se mettre en économie guerre
pour reprendre le propos qui est aussi
parfois utilisée pour illustrer
l'ampleur des transformations qu'il y a
à faire pour changer le monde qui nous
entoure
on ne peut faire ça que en changeant de
paradigme l'enjeu c'est amusant parce
que pendant que jean-françois rappeler
ce qu'était le péché dans la bible
j'étais justement en train de me
regarder parce que moi je suis un
mécréant j'ai regardé j'ai révisé la
liste des péchés capitaux et j'en ai
quand même vu trois ou quatre qui sont
en fait des péchés anti sobriété
il me semble que l'on peut mettre dans
cette catégorie la gourmandise la luxure
l'envi et l'avarice
ça en fait au moins quatre qui sont
dépêchés anti sobriété
par ailleurs une autre chose que je que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que à l'époque
où l'énergie étaient rares chers
en fait la bulle à la religion et en
particulier l'église catholique était la
seule multinationale mondiale il y en
avait pas deux véhicules de
multinationales et c'était une
multinationale des valeurs c'était pas
une multinationale des biens ou des
services
c'était une multinationale des valeurs
et de la haie de là alors sera pas
toujours été de tout repos l'inquisition
en espagne ça quand même pas été un
moment très rigolo pour ce qui en fait
les frais et si on en croit si on pense
que les visiteurs est un témoignage
fidèle de la manière dont la question se
passait dans l'ancien temps voilà de
temps en temps c'était un système qui
n'allait pas sans quelques effets de
bord mais il n'empêche que encore une
fois à cette époque là il y avait que
les valeurs pour faire tenir les gens
ensemble vous pouvez pas le faire avec
le commerce ou avec les biens et les
services et donc dans ce monde de demain
qui se promet hélas ou heureusement 2
venir par la force des choses plus
économe en flux tout simplement parce
que nous vivons sur une planète finie et
donc que ça va advenir de toute façon il
est essentiel me semble-t-il de
retravailler ce chantier des valeurs et
en fait quand tu les vois aujourd'hui
par exemple l'opposition entre les gens
qui veulent du libéralisme et les gens
qui veulent qu'on réglemente ça n'est
rien d'autre qu'un combat de valeur
quand on voit alors sur un terrain que
je trouve un peu plus nauséabond
personnellement mais quand on voit
aujourd'hui le débat qu'il ya entre eux
est ce qu'on accueille lorsqu'on
accueille pas les étrangers qui veulent
venir s'installer chez doucet teintées
pas de valeur c'est pas un débat
économique et donc on est en train de
voir monter clairement là je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec jean-françois aussi
le débat sur les valeurs ou là où le
retour des valeurs et il me semble que
là où les gens comme moi peuvent essayer
de faire très modestement recrute il
c'est de faire en sorte que ses valeurs
elle nous entraîne vers le positif et
non pas vers le négatif car elles
peuvent très bien faire les deux
l'histoire l'a malheureusement amplement
trouver
je pense toujours que nous sommes des
animaux mû par nos sens avant d'être
nous ne sommes que chili comme disait je
de cet outil comme constituée de
molécules avec départ d'interaction dans
tous les sens et donc le la question du
désir du sens de l'éthique etc sont
effectivement des questions centrales là
où le sujet devient ainsi on bascule sur
des considérations très pratique un peu
plus difficile a fait un peu plus
difficile pardon à manier c'est que
finalement il ya qu' il ya que deux
manières de faire de ce sujet qui est
initialement un sujet de physique et un
sujet technique un sujet sociétal est un
sujet de valeur soit que les ingénieurs
deviennent de bons philosophe mais enfin
si je prends mon propre cas réussissent
au bac de philo c'est pas gagné d'avancé
soit que les gens dont le métier est de
s'intéresser aux valeurs s'intéresse
particulièrement à cette question des
limites planétaires et les seuils de m
la profession des valeurs qui font en
accord avec ses limites planétaires
c'est pour ça que j'ai évidemment comme
beaucoup de gens très intéressés par
l'encyclique date aussi
et que d'une manière générale quand il y
a une volonté de la part d'un mouvement
religieux qui compte donc il y en a en
gros 3 sur cette plage à 3,4 sur cette
planète de commencer à s'intéresser à ce
genre de sujet et dans le monde
occidental c'est quand même de manière
très dominante la chrétienté
eh bien il me semble que c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est quelque chose
qui doit être encouragé et donc
jean-françois on me voit ministre moi je
pense qu'il ya un rôle plus important
que le bien est devenu un apôtre
c'est à dire que s'il arrive à infuser
une partie croissante de la communauté
chrétienne de france et du monde
sur cette question du respect des
limites planétaires il n'aura pas perdu
son temps et moi non plus si j'arrive à
l'en convaincre donc ces quelques je
pense que ça bougera les gens encore
plus que le ministre puisque pour en
revenir par là où j'ai commencé cette
affaire du respect des limites
planétaires est avant tout un sujet d'un
sujet de valeur et oui je l' ai déjà dit
je ne travaille pas assez parce
qu'encore une fois c'est mes propres
limites à moi mais il est absolument
évident que la mise en oeuvre d'un plan
d'organisation massive de la sobriété
d'une certaine manière ne peut être
désirable ou à tout le moins acceptable
que dans un monde où les valeurs ou un
peu changé par rapport à aujourd'hui et
toute la question est de savoir comment
y arrive
et je m'arrête là je me vois ça laisse
du temps aux questions et ça laisse du
temps à les changes
merci pour ces réflexions intéressantes
et stimulantes
donc on va passer à ce second temps qui
est consacré aux réactions et au
dialogue entre vous deux alors je laisse
jean françois moureau peut-être real
giroud commenter ce qui a été dit par
jean marc jancovici
alors jean-françois tués oui voilà c'est
bon oui oui je disais merci beaucoup
pour pour ses présentations marque je
crois qu on est assez d'accord sur pas
mal de choses
et
alors j'avais une question tu parlais
des péchés capitaux est utilisée qu' il
y en avait plusieurs qui était en tissu
anti sobriété et au contraire tu veux
dire qu'ils encouragent à la sobriété
c'est ça que tu voulais dire oui
absolument ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est des péchés capitaux qui explique
que la sobrena comportement non sobre
est un comportement répréhensible
d'accord oui oui ok oui et je pense
qu'effectivement la société notamment
midi médiévale a montré un certain
nombre d'exemples de de frugalité de
sobriété en partie volontaires notamment
aussi à travers l'abolition des ce cas
la jaquette quand même été abolie deux
fois une première fois dans l'occident
au travers justement de cette morale
chrétienne allez les questions sur
exactement comment cet esclavage a été
abolie et pourrait faire l'objet de
discussions un peu un peu plus longue
mais en tout cas je pense effectivement
que l'occident chrétien a joué un rôle
dans une preuve dans la promotion d'une
certaine forme de sobriété notamment à
travers les mouvements
[Musique]
monarchique et c'est
donc voilà alors c'est vrai que pour
rebondir sur ce que tu disais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec toi que
malheureusement je crains aussi que il
fasse qu'il faille une crise majeure
pour que les choses changent
véritablement
je pense aussi d'ailleurs
que je suis aussi pas certain que si la
crise majeure arrive on devra procéder
par étapes ou si d'autres mesures comme
la le rationnement ne seront pas plus
efficaces et parce que je prends un
exemple pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale ou quand en angleterre
notamment
il a été question de rationner l'énergie
la nourriture et c'est justement s'est
posé des questions en anglais ce qu'on
réduit
progressivement par exemple à une taxe
ou est ce qu on rationne et ce qui a
fonctionné c'est le rationnement est en
fait en angleterre le rationnement a été
beaucoup mieux vécu qu'en france un
disque en france il a été en partie
imposée par l'allemagne et en angleterre
il a été imposé par le gouvernement
pour des questions de justice et
notamment les personnes modestes en
angleterre était mieux nourris pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale qu'avant la
guerre donc ça ça rejoint d'ailleurs ce
que tu disais dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
sur le fait qu' il peut y avoir des tas
de bénéfices secondaires à une forme de
sobriété et par exemple par rapport à la
seconde guerre mondiale aussi je sais
que des rapports disait aussi que une
simple voiture qui traversait long
avec un conducteur une voiture de
loisirs un papa un peu une ambulance ou
quelque chose comme ça faisait plus pour
démoraliser les gens que
tout autre chose parce que ça mettant en
valeur
l'injustice si quelqu'un avait le droit
entre guinée de se permettait de voyager
dans une voiture individuelle alors que
c'était interdit etc ça s'appelle le
moral est donc en fait pour dire que
parfois des mesures plus radicales de
d'arrêt de de la consommation est
peut-être plus efficace qu'un qu'une
diminution progressive
alors je vais rebondir sur ce dernier
point je pense que c'est pas hasard
enfin exactement c'est très convergent
avec ce que tu viens de dire le fait qu'
énormément de gens disent je veux bien
faire un effort mais qu'en même temps
que machin se goinfrent aura devant
droit il n'en est pas question et en
fait il ya un souci d'équité dans le
inversement les gens qui sont un peu
passés à la postérité comme étant des
gens qui sont capables de fédérer autour
d'eux dans l'effort sont souvent des
gens dont on disait que leur
comportement était exemplaire
ça peut être justement
pour reprendre des personnages qui ont
été cités l'abbé pierre ou mère teresa
ou dans un autre registre de gaulle qui
était devant ses troupes à prendre les
balles avant reçu bien et devait y en
avoir une qui passait par là donc c'est
c'est je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose sur lequel le pouvoir
politique ne travaillent pas assez
et quand castex scandalise tout le monde
parce qu'il prend à jet privé pour aller
voter c'est pas tant la dépense
énergétique marginal et qui va
occasionner dans l'ensemble de la
défense française qui compte parce que
des gens qui prennent un jet privé pour
aller voter quand même pas beaucoup
c'est même pas le fait qu' il ait eu
le droit entre guillemets encore
quelques semaines
aux attributs de sa fonction c'est parce
que ça représente quelque chose qui est
considéré comme étant faites ce que je
dis pas ce que je fais est donc dans
l'effort il devrait y avoir un côté
particulièrement exemplaire
alala
comportement des gens qui appellent
eux-mêmes à ce qu'on se mobilise autour
de ce genre de problème exactement comme
dans l'ancien temps sauf erreur de ma
part si le curé été pris en train de se
vautrer dans les pâtisseries et la bonne
chère ce qu'ils croient ils faisaient de
temps en temps en fait ces ouailles
considéré qu' il y avait quelque chose
de très répréhensibles dans son
comportement
donc il ya et c'est évident pour moi
qu'il ya deux considérations qui sont
extrêmement liés dans cette affaire qui
sont la sobriété et l'équité je vois mal
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
une organisation collective
ainsi dans les gens à devenir sobre sans
que derrière il ya une forme d'équité
qui pour dire les choses très simplement
signifie que les gens comme moi ce
entendu beaucoup plus vite que les gens
de l'étagé en dessous
et des gens à l'étagé au dessus du mien
c'est entendu encore plus fier ça paraît
sa part est absolument évident il doit y
avoir c'est doit s'accompagner de
quelques choses de cette nature et le
rationnement est quelque chose de
terriblement ethiquable parce que alors
hors effets de bord du marché noir riche
ou pauvre pas si on a droit à 300 g de
pain par jour c'est tout le monde et je
pense que pour faire écho à un épisode
récent l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
le produit confinement a été vécue sans
beaucoup de grogne c'est que justement
il était vu initialement avant qu'on se
rende compte que tous les confinements
n'ont pas été égaux et que selon qu'on
était confiné dans sa datcha avec un
grand jardin ou dans un appartement du
nord de paris sans balcon sens sans
balcon et ce en cours c'était pas pareil
mais on a quand même vécu ça comme riche
ou pauvre pas de passe-droit tout le
monde reste chez soi et donc c'est
quelque chose est riche ou pauvre vous
montez pas d'envoi de voitures et donc
ça je pense que ça a rendu la chose
particulièrement acceptable et donc je
suis alors que j'étais un grand partisan
de la taxe carbone dans l'ancien temps
comme moyen de commencer à régler
progressivement le problème je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
malheureusement trop attendu et si on
veut des mesures rapides elles devront
être essentiellement réglementaire c'est
à dire essentiellement des formes de
rationnement bien pensé et accepter
c'est très clair dans mon esprit que
c'est comme ça que ça doit s'organiser
et en fait toutes les mesures du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
sont des mesures dont réglementaire pour
l'essentiel on parle quasiment pas de
fiscalité parce que effectivement et là
ça me renvoie encore une valeur
l'équité fait que on supporte mieux
quelque chose qui est identique pour
tous à une forme de passe-droit
particulièrement en france qui est comme
je le dis parfois en rigolant le seul
pays communistes d'europe de l'ouest
nous avons quand même une mentalité très
égalitariste et donc la notion de passe
droit sauf quand on en bénéficie elle
est quelque chose qu'on supporte
particulièrement mal
merci
josette je ne sais pas si du coup on
continue le dialogue ou si tu ouvres
aux autres je sais pas aux questions du
live on a encore un peu de temps donc si
tu souhaites j'ai passé deux étés dit tu
peux
ok bah moi j'avais une question en fait
pour toi jean marc s'était finalement tu
donc tu as bien clarifier le fait que
pour toi le plan de transformation de
l'économie française n'est pas
directement
applicable en l'état effectivement le
fait que quand même 75 % les français à
peu près ont voté pour dédé des
programmes de candidats qui n'était pas
véritablement compatible avec nos
objectifs notamment de réduction de gaz
à effet de serre en
pour tenir les objectifs climat puisque
le chiffre est aussi un une étude des
programmes des candidats donc
donc d'un côté tu dis donc que tu penses
que l'on pourra pas mettre en oeuvre ce
plan tant qu'on n'aura pas finalement
une certaine
crise qui va nous permettre de changer
de paradigme et comme tu l'as dit aussi
il ya encore cinq élections cinq mandats
présidentiels c'est aussi possible que
même si le plan a commencé à être mis en
place dans les prochaines
dans les prochaines vingt mettons la
prochaine
cette échéance présidentielle ici
maintenant donc ils commencent est-ce
que elle pourrait être de nouveau
retournez à la prochaine élection
présidentielle si un candidat parce
qu'il ne souhaite pas mettre en oeuvre
donc finalement face à ça qu'est-ce que
tu préconises est-ce que tu préconises
de juste continuer pas qu'elle ait
finalement maintenant que vous avez fait
ce plan de l'économie française avec le
shift quelle est la prochaine étape
qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu comptes
faire
puisque finalement à part susciter une
crise que évidemment j'imagine tu n'as
pas envie de faire
quel est le telle est la prochaine étape
la prochaine étape va arriver tout seul
en fait la prochaine étape c'est une
gare en ukraine un peu augmenté c'est
pourquoi les détroit d'ormuz qui est
bloqué c'est une pandémie c'est une
démondialisation accéléré pour dieu sait
quelle raison cfa elle va arriver tout
c'est le défaut de l'espagne et de
l'italie j'en sais rien fall barragué
tout seul la prochaine étape comme je le
disais dans mon aura-t-il intervention
liminaire en fait c'est le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
sera peut-être remis par quelqu'un
comment dire qui ce qui s'avérera être
le chef inattendu tout simplement parce
qu'il était là au moment où les choses
se passent et qu'à ce moment c'est lui
qui se retrouve en charge de mettre en
oeuvre quelque chose
qui n'a qu'une qu'il n'avait pas
envisagé de mettre en oeuvre avant donc
je pense qu'on va être un peu poussé par
les circonstances
ceux ci essaye de faire un peu de
politique fiction
à défaut de faire un peu de religion
fiction
le on pourrait imaginer quelque chose en
deux temps c'est à dire que dans un
premier temps il ya une crise qui fait
que le titulaire du poste commence à
essayer de faire ce qu'il peut et puis
ici il n'arrive pas à faire assez à ce
moment il est renversé
je ne sais pas ce qui peut se passer la
seule chose qui me paraît peu probable
mais c'est peut-être parce que quand on
devient vieux on devient pessimiste
c'est qu'on est encore cinq élections
présidentielles tranquille d'ici à 2050
dans un monde qui ne s'occuperait pas du
problème
parle pas complètement gagné d'avancé
par contre
qu'est ce qui va se passer à la
prochaine crise je ne sais pas là on a
vu que à l'occasion de la crise en
d'ukraine tout d'un coup les européens
décident de quelque chose qui n'avait
pas sur leurs écrans radar dans
je ne sais pas non plus quel rôle va
jouer la religion justement en tant que
mouvement sociétal fédéral on le voit
bien dans une espèce de combat de
civilisation le rôle que jouent certains
groupes musulmans
quelques elle quel rôle va jouer la
religion dominante d'occident est ce
qu'elle va rester là où elle est c'est à
dire quand même assez peu présent dans
la gestion des affaires des affaires
civiles est ce qu'on va voir le retour
je ne sais pas j'ai beaucoup de mal à
faire quoi que ce soit comme pronostics
pour pouvoir venir juste finir ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur les péchés en
fait les péchés alors pendant une vision
très utilitariste de la religion on
pourrait faire remarquer que les flécher
n'était qu'encourager à l'époque les
gens à suivre leurs propres intérêts
c'est-à-dire dans un monde de peu dans
un nombre limité
l'intérêt des gens c'était de s'en
accommoder et d'être fataliste parce que
sinon ils étaient au règlement
malheureux donc on pourrait dire quelque
part que la morale religieuse de
l'époque ne faisait qu essayer de faire
en sorte que les gens s'accommodent au
mieux de l'univers qui était le leur à
l'époque et quand on regarde des
aliments interdits par exemple dans la
religion musulmane ou juive on tombe
aussi assez facilement sur des trucs qui
se conservent pas bien là où ces
religions sont les donc
si on poursuit dans la voie
qui va peut être choquer certains de ces
préceptes religieux un peu utilitariste
finalement un peu en phase avec l'époque
ça serait pas étonnant que sous une
forme ou sous une autre on voit en quoi
une renaissance du fait religieux dans
les décennies qui viennent et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure en fait la
seule question c'est de savoir qui ou
quoi ce radieux puisque une forme
d'engagement politique très fort tiens
pour moi un peu du même ressort
émotionnel c'est se retrouver autour de
quelque chose qui fait sens pour tout le
monde et qui est un qui est un projet
commun portant sur les valeurs portant
sur des croyances parce qu'au bout du
bout c'est la croyance à l'avenir cet
appareil à vis des autres le et ait pas
effectivement c'est c'est le calcul
n'est qu'un instrument de cette de ce
projet à ce moment là
alors juste si je peux te poser une
question encore ce que je crois qu'après
on va laisser la parole aux auditeurs
aussi c'est du coup est ce que toi tu
garde un espoir dans cette dans ce monde
où tu as quand même travaillé longtemps
à présent à préparer un plan
transformation économique française qui
est un peu la dernière entre les
méchants ce qu'on peut avoir de demain
de garder nos objectifs nationaux en
tout cas de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre alors on part on pardonnera cette
part-là grandiloquent mais enfin bon il
faut bien que je choisisse un personnage
pas dû pour illustrer ce que je pense
est-ce que l'abbé pierre ils avaient
l'espoir d'éradiquer les gens mal logés
ou il a simplement fait quelque chose
qui faisait sens pour lui est ce que
coluche avait l'espoir d'éradiquer les
gens qui ont du mal à se nourrir ou il a
juste fait un truc qui faisait sens pour
lui je pense que dans les deux cas de
figure au moins la deuxième réponse
était suffisante à leur bonheur
là je vais faire la même au moins la
deuxième réponse est suffisante à mon
bonheur c'est à dire j'essaie et comme
tu me l'a fait remarquer tout à l'heure
au moins j'aurai essayé
et
pour une partie significative de mézos
réveiller ben ça suffit à mon bonheur
c'est une bonne réponse en tout cas en
ce qui me concerne
merci d'en marquer
merci à vous deux pour ces interactions
intéressante et et inspirante on va
passer donc autant d'interaction avec
avec nos auditeurs et cette première
question qui est posée à vous deux quand
je parle à mes parents de la nécessité
de la sobriété mon père fini par me dire
on a patrie mais toute notre vie pour se
priver il a 70 ans le boomer par
excellence que lui répondent
qu'ils se lancent comme il en a un mais
il
ya une réponse rationnelle et une
réponse affective la réponse rationnelle
n'aura strictement aucun point qu'il va
falloir tenter la réponse affective la
réponse rationnelle c'est que il fait
partie des gens qui se seront privés de
rien
70 ans il est né dans l'abondance eelv
aura dans une relative abondance et il
sera et tout ça dans un monde en paix
enfin exactement dans un pays en paix et
c'est inédit dans l'histoire des hommes
donc je pense que il
la réponse rationnelle c'est de lui dire
qu'il y plane ils seront par contre y'a
l'ouest comme on dit
peut-être que la réponse un peu
un peu plus utile c'est de lui demander
de quoi ils se privent dans cette
histoire dit autrement
est ce que est ce que l'idée en
particulier de priver ses enfants
liberté est quelque chose qui l'ennuie
ou pas parce que de fait
en refusant de contribuer à un effort il
contribue à ce que la situation
devienne éventuellement plus désagréable
et les gens qu'ils vont payer
l'essentiel de la facture c'est pas lui
puisqu'il est proche de la mort 70 ans
c'est lé successeur donc en fait en
disant ça il dit quelque part
je me contrefiche de l'équité
intergénérationnelle et je me
désintéresse raisonnablement du sort de
mes descendants et ça c'est peut-être
une réponse sur le terrain des valeurs
qui l'asticot sera plus c'est qu'il
achètera plus à réfléchir
ainsi si je peux compléter moi je crois
que ce genre de réponse ne le mettrait
probablement en colère si mes parents me
disaient ça donc je compatis avec vous
je pense qu'on pourrait reprendre les
trois arguments utilisés
dans la première partie de ma réponse à
dire que il ya d'une part le il faut
mieux choisir la sobriété que de la
vivre et que de que de subir la pauvreté
parce que ça peut arriver plus vite que
ce qu'on peut croire même à 70 ans il a
encore 20 ans d'espérance de vie comme
le rappelait jean marc tout à l'heure il
n'est pas du tout certain que ça soit
tranquille les 20 prochaines années par
ailleurs qui a plein de kobe néfissa
adopter un mode de vie plus sobres et
que en fait ce que encore une fois on
nous présente comme étant une vie une
bonne vie c'est souvent une vie qui
n'est pas forcément si les panneaux me
sente whip and win que ça
et donc voilà et puis si il est si la la
fois je ne sais pas à la question de
l'eau dit pas je pourrais aller aussi
sur le domaine de la foi justement pour
lui dire mais
finalement est ce que il est ce que est
ce que la bible n'est ce que notre foi
chrétienne ne nous appelle pas
se préoccuper justement comme le
rappelait jean marc du sort des
générations futures du sort des pauvres
de ceux qui souffrent déjà aujourd'hui
du problème du changement climatique etc
et l'interpellé sur sur ce sujet de la
foi alors c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'on
soit aidée par les églises sens au
pluriel que ces églises vienne challenge
est aussi ce discours qu'on entend
souvent et puis dernier point je
pourrais dire aussi je pense que ce qui
pourrait aider dans ce cas c'est celui
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure de les
quitter je peux comprendre d'un point de
vue strictement je dirais humain le fait
qu'on n'a pas tellement de se priver si
d'autres ne se prive pas alors
typiquement c'est
les américains les chinois ou les
capitalistes où les riches ou je sais
pas quoi mais c'est vrai que si il ya un
effort qui est consenti de façon égale
par toute la société je pense que dans
ce cas là ça sera plus facile pour votre
père d'accepter
cette suggestion
merci toujours sur pour prolonger la
question de l'équité mais un niveau
plutôt international une personne pose
la question suivante comment réfléchir à
ce sujet ans
dans l'optique des pays pauvres versus
les pays occidentaux les premiers
aspirent au minimum vital et sont
vraiment loin du débat de nos vélos
électriques
alors là je peux tenter une réponse en
deux temps la première c'est que quand
on regarde les enquêtes d'opinion sur
qui est perturbée par le changement
climatique sur terre en fait les pays
dits pauvres sont en général plus
sensible que les pays occidentaux j'ai
souvent entendu dire à le changement
climatique c'est une préoccupation
riches les pauvres ils s'en foutent de
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est crottés
ouais enfin sauf que les pauvres vivent
dans des en fait c'est quoi être bourrin
c'est avoir peu d'énergie et en fait
c'est ça le quand on regarde sur le plan
physique c'est d'avoir peu de moyens
matériels et donc avoir peu d'énergie
c'est exactement ça
après on peut normandie certeza je
laisserais sa jean-françois sur qu'est
ce qui est profond mais
non mais s4 est simple et elle est un
être pur c'est toute la question
finalement mais le met donc c'est des
gens qui ont peu d'énergie et comme
c'est des gens qui ont peu d'énergie et
peu de moyens c'est aussi des gens qui
sont peu armés pour répondre aux aléas
de l'environnement et donc en fait c'est
des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
sensibles aux caprices de la météo et du
climat et donc paradoxalement les pays
dits pauvres ils sont pas moins motivés
que nous à ce qu'on s'occupe
sérieusement de la question du
changement climatique et ce qui veut
dire qu'à partir du moment où ils sont
motivés dans la mesure de leurs moyens
évidemment ils seront nécessairement
prêt à prendre une part à l'effort
c'est un premier un premier point le
deuxième point c'est que
cette expression enfin il ya une limite
aux jésuitisme on peut pas à la fois
l'heure est allé sous le nez notre mode
de vie et puis dire ensuite à bas vous
voyez ils en ont envie donc 1 il ya
qu'elle ait laissé faire bon ça c'est
quand même un comportement qui consiste
bon je vais t'expliquer qu'il faut pas
que tu fumes mais je vais commencer par
fuguer abondamment devant toi puis je te
dirai c'est pas bien faut surtout pas
faire ça c'est évident qu'à un moment il
faut quand même qu'on se mettre d'accord
avec nous mêmes à partir du moment où on
explique qu'il faut aller dans une
certaine direction commençons par le
faire et après on verra bien si les
autres ils aspirent à faire différemment
nous
[Musique]
donc le enfin dernier point la loi qui
revient plus sur le terrain du
rationalisme de toute façon il n'y a pas
assez de place sur terre il n'y a pas
assez de ressources pour que les pays
dits pauvres vivent un jour comme et de
manière durable
comme les classes moyennes des pays
occidentaux qui a pas assez donc ça
n'arrivera pas voilà donc la bonne
question c'est vers quoi on converge et
qu'est ce que nous on est prêts ouf on a
accepté comme sobriété en échange d'un
monde stable moins instable
aujourd'hui la paix n'est absolument pas
incluse dans la façon pas dans le prix
des produits sains il n'y a pas la paix
dans le prix des produits si la paix
était comprise dans le prix des produits
il y en a certains qui devrait
considérablement plus cher donc
c'est c'est un raisonnement
et je vais finir par une petite pique
si les gens se soucier temps des pauvres
ou directement des pays pauvres il ya
longtemps que la véritable aide au
développement française aurait dépassé 0
5% du pib il sera plutôt à 20 ou 25 donc
voilà donc quoi pour moi c'est un peu un
cache-sexe cette histoire c'est quand
même des gens qui au fond avant taux des
prétextes parce qu ils ont pas envie de
faire des efforts
oui je pourrais complété en disant que
effectivement peut-être dans un certain
nombre de pays du sud parce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la préoccupation
pour les questions écologiques pour le
changement climatique et les
proportionnelle en tout cas c'était le
cas jusqu'à ya pas longtemps j'ai pas vu
d'études récentes sur le sujet mais
proportionnel au niveau d'études donc
toutes choses étant égales par ailleurs
plus on a fait des études et plus on
s'intéresse à la crise climatique par
exemple et donc ça veut pas dire
évidemment que certains qui n'ont pas
fait d'études ne s'intéressent pas la
question ou que certains qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études ne semblait intéresse
pas mais donc déjà peut-être aussi dans
un certain nombre de potentiellement des
intérêts de la question dans certains
pays du sud ça peut venir aussi d'une
moindre information de moins d'accès à
l'éducation à la formation sur le sujet
après je crois qu'effectivement il faut
garder une notion d'équité c'est à dire
que il ya il ya une quinzaine d'années
en arrière il y avait un
plan qui était assez utopique mais qui
s'appelait contraction et convergence
ces dernières qui visait à faire en
sorte que le niveau de vie des pays dits
pauvres rejoignent celui des pays et
dirige c'est à dire qu'il ya un
événement donc effectivement c'est vers
ça que en théorie on aimerait aller
après dans la pratique c'est un petit
peu comme le communisme on voit que ça
ne marche pas toujours très bien
communiquer d'ailleurs soit dit en
passant qui est pour reprendre
l'expression de jean marc tout à leurs
derniers pays communistes d'europe le
communisme était définie par line white
qui était un historien qui a
qui a écrit un article sur les origines
de la crise écologique qui accuse un
article christianisme d'avoir été à
l'origine la crise écologique comme la
dernière hérésie chrétienne
donc c'est une
voilà donc dans le sens où ça rejoint
aussi les idées d'équité qui sont
développés dans la bible justice sociale
etc donc je pense que il faut
effectivement que les pays pauvres
puissent sortir de leur pauvreté avec
une aide au développement qui soit
ciblée mais une année de développement
qui n'entraîne pas les mêmes
désagréments que ce que ça entraîneur
mon pays donc effectivement comme le
disait jean marc il faut éviter de de
détaler notre notre mode de vie partout
et d'encourager et de montrer les
limites aussi de notre mode de vie qui
ne rend pas les gens heureux parce que
un autre point qu'on pourrait développer
c'est que le niveau de vie ne naît pas
enfin le niveau de bonheur n'est pas
n'est pas directement lié à haut niveau
dire il ya des corrélations mais pas
qu'ils fonctionnent pas complètement
et justement je me posais la question
si ce n'est plus notre consommation qui
nous rend heureux
pour vous quelles seraient les autres
levier d'épanouissement dans une société
de la sobriété
on en revient c'était le propos
introductifs de tout à l'heure on en
revient à la question des valeurs
alors qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça amène
là
il ça ramène le sens ça amène une forme
de sécurité
parce que se sentir inséré dans un
collectif ça ramène une forme de
sécurité
voilà mais on on va nécessairement
basculer sur quelque chose qui relève de
la dea
[Musique]
oui mais
moi je pense que demain ce que je disais
tout à l'heure aussi dans son propos
introductif c'était de dire que de
dénoncer finalement c'est eux
ce mensonge de nous laisser croire à
travers la publicité à travers tout un
discours un peu on entend partout que
plus on a de de biens et plus on est
heureux
et c'est le slogan j'avais utilisé c'est
pas moi qui les ai inventées plus de
plus de liens moins de biens en moins de
biens plus de liens c'est à dire qu'en
fait on se rend compte que dans
la technologie ou les biens de
consommation
loin de faire de nous des gens plus
heureux alors évidemment dans une il
faut pas être
indigents et à la rue ainsi non ça c'est
pas une source de bonheur quand on est
trop pauvre mais quand on est trop riche
vous voyez les riches autour de nous ils
sont pas forcément très heureux c'est
pas la richesse c'est pas l'argent c'est
paraît peut-être une
une lapalissade ce que je dis ou
peut-être quelque chose de très beau
même de très évident on est en fait ça a
tout à fait le problème c'est de montrer
à quel point
on peut avoir de l'épanouissement dans
d'autres choses est ce que disait jean
marc est ce que je vis aussi
personnellement c'est que ce qui me
procure du bonheur c'est pas les gains
de consommation c'est de faire un
travail que j'espère utile de travailler
à alerter l'opinion sur cette question
du changement climatique par exemple me
donne beaucoup plus de bonheur et de
satisfaction que
les biens de consommation pourrait me
donner voilà c'est de dénoncer
finalement dénoncé ce mensonge de la
société de consommation qui est une
forme à mon sens d'un point de vue
religieux une forme d'idolâtrie
pour ça qu'on utilise aussi des mots
comme temple de la consommation ou
voilà et c'est donc on voit bien qu'il
ya une connotation religieuse d'ailleurs
je vous renvoie un petit à petit une
petite vidéo qui est disponible sur
youtube gratuitement qui s'appelle
l'histoire des shows the story of stuff
qui a une citation fabuleuse d'un
économiste des années 50 qui explique
que la société de consommation a été
pensée exprès communes comme quelque
chose de religieux pour et créer créer
des rituels qui amène les gens à
consommer comme avant ils allaient
l'église d'une certaine façon et le père
noël a remplacé
jésus christ le jour de noël il amène
des cadeaux il ya une vraie une
substitution intéressante je pourrai
débloquer plus longues et donc c'est
pour moi la solution c'est de dénoncer
c'est ce mensonge et d' inviter à aller
justement vers des réponses spirituel
aller vers
évidemment je prêche pour ma paroisse
c'est le cas du bed-in vers une forme de
2,2 de rapprochement avec dieu et avec
son prochain parce que le véritable les
vrais véritable satisfaction dans la vie
pour moi bien de sa dalle et de chercher
dieu et de chercher à être en contact
avec ses proches son prochain ce que
jean marc que expliqué bien aussi le
phénomène d'appartenir à un collectif à
un groupe voilà dans la surconsommation
il ya un côté frénésie un côté perte de
contrôle en fait il ya un côté où on
n'est pas capable de se maîtriser je
suis pas capable de résister aux soldes
je suis pas capable de résister aux
trucs aux emballages avec du rouge du
bleu du vert du jaune que je vois est
allé partout autour de moi
en fait je ne suis pas capable de
résister alors c'est évident que entre
consommation une surconsommation il ya
quand même une marge
le titre qui habite dans la rue on peut
difficilement lui avait reproché de
vouloir qu'elle un logement en dur en
tout cas c'est tellement aujourd'hui
devenu la norme et puis il faut quand
même reconnaître que c'est quand même
plus sympa de dormir dans un logement en
dur que de dormir dans la rue ça il ya
quand même une énorme différence par
contre est-ce qu'il ya une énorme
différence entre le fait d'avoir deux
vestes et le fait d'en avoir 50 pas sûr
donc il ya il ya des
c'est évidemment un vieux débat de
savoir ce qu'on appelle le minimum
hi mom vital est ce que le minimum vital
c'est de vivre dans un logement en dur
avec dix mètres carrés par personne doit
être 40 mètres carrés par personne pour
voilà ça c'est des questions importantes
mais
c'est pareil pour la mobilité on est des
animaux donc on a besoin de se déplacer
mais est ce que le minimum vital c'est
pouvoir se déplacer à pied à vélo ou le
minimum vital c'est pouvoir se déplacer
en voiture
donc il ya eu tout un débat à voir aussi
sur comment est ce que on abaisse
progressivement le seuil de ce qu'on
considère comme étant le minimum vital
matériel sans que pour autant deviennent
neurasthénique donc en fait on a basculé
enfin on a oscillé entre deux obstacles
qui se répondent qu'ils aient la
frénésie d'un côté et la neurasthénie
chi le le le
voilà les l'excès de dénuement
de l'autre côté et c'est pas ça à
l'évidence à l'évidence c'est pas ça que
je ne suis pas sûr du reste que
l'humanité maurer en ayant trouvé
exactement comment définir le seuil de
la juste consommation à mon avis on
trouvera jamais mais par contre ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui c'est encourager
à
considérer comme désirable encore une
fois le fait de se contenter de moins
parce que ça va avec une forme de
maîtrise de soi
oublié où justement d'être d'être dans
une forme de non maîtrise
ce qui est quand même un peu quelque
part le désir du toujours plus
merci une question maintenant peut-être
plus particulièrement pour jean françois
moreau puisqu'il a été question dans vos
interventions de la bible et des
chrétiens une personne se demande si la
bible défend la sobriété dirais tu que
les chrétiens sont à la hauteur de leurs
idéaux sinon pourquoi
alors non malheureusement les chrétiens
sont pas du tout à la hauteur moi le
premier dans le sens où
je les dis il ya eu beaucoup de 2,2 de
dérive l'église à mon avis depuis 200
ans à c'est quand même très largement
fourvoyé les églises je parle de toutes
les églises n'y a pas eu de deux
différences majeures je pense
donc oui je dirais que les églises ont
adopté la société de consommation à bras
ouverts ils ont
la sauce il existe vraiment jouer son
rôle de frein mais pour prendre un peu
la défense quand même des générations
pressés qui m'ont précédé je pense que
si elle est vécue au xviiie siècle au
début de la révolution industrielle
j'aurais embrasser la révolution
industrielle aussi s'en méfier à
l'époque c'était quand même
génial ce que ça proposait un oracle
explique dr dansant dans sa bd un monde
sans fin ça nous a donné des pouvoirs
extraordinaires ça ne fait nous en
quelque sorte des surhommes et ça a
permis aussi d'un point de vue des
chrétiens de balle et évangéliser ce qui
était quand même la préoccupation numéro
un des chrétiens les évangéliser de par
le monde on met aussi fin
l'évangélisation aller de pair avec la
construction d'hôpitaux avec la
construction de deux de chemin de fer
donc le progrès était vu comme quelque
chose qui allait permettre de
d'amener la prospérité occidental dans
beaucoup de pays colonisés etc alors
évidemment il ya eu aussi des gens qui
avaient pas des bonnes intentions mais
il y en a aussi qui avaient des bonnes
intentions et donc tout d'abord dire que
oui l'église a failli à sa mission
giresse est pas nouveau la ville de
toute façon nous nous montre que des
histoires de du peuple hébreu aussi qui
systématiquement tombe à côté de la
plaque mais c'est pas la faute des
israélites c'est de la faute de la
nature humaine je pense qu'il fait qu on
a beaucoup de mal à rester dans le plan
de dieu et dans les commandements de
dieu mais ceci dit comme je disais je
pense que il y a possibilité de de se
repentir
de la bible dit à plusieurs reprises que
quand on quand le peuple réalise qu'il a
fait une erreur se repent au sens de
changer de voie de changer de direction
de réaliser son erreur et que il prie
dieu promet qu' il vient et qui guérit
même le pays c'est le linge quand ça a
notamment à l'inversé dans deux
chroniques 7,14 et je crois
fondamentalement ça c'est à dire je
pense que dieu qu'il sait comment il
nous a il nous a créé il sait qu'on est
des animaux faillible et je pense qu'il
aura pitié de nous quand je pense qu'on
est on est pris en fait dans un piège
faustien ça c'est un journaliste
britannique s'est un jour mon bios qui a
expliqué sa queue il fait un parallèle
entre l'histoire de faussetés l'histoire
de de l'addiction des des hommes aux
énergies fossiles qui nous devons les
énergies fossiles qui nous ont donné des
pouvoirs comme comme ils ont donné des
pouvoirs à fos et l'histoire se termine
évidemment en enfer qui est symbolisé
qui pourrait symboliser le changement
climatique donc je crois à la fois à la
culpabilité de l'église mais je dirais
qui a suivi la société en général c'est
pas juste l'église et en même temps je
implore le la la clémence finalement
vis-à-vis d'eux deux maisons de mes
prédécesseurs des
hommes et des femmes de foi dans les
siècles passés parce que il n'avait pas
conscience jusqu'à ya pas longtemps de
ce qui se passait du piège dans lequel
on était je pense que notre qualité à
notre génération est beaucoup plus
importante parce que là nous par contre
on sait pertinemment ce qui se passe et
on ne fait pas grand chose mais bon on a
aussi des excuses dans le sens où
on peut bien faire des plans comme
jean-marc l'a fait et pourtant on ne
sait pas comment les appliquer tant que
ya pas une masse critique qui suis né on
est tout à la fois coupable et en même
temps innocent je pense
le plan en question si je peux faire une
remarque il est il a quand même un
intérêt
c'est qu'en fait il permet à l'occasion
de son de sa conception de fédérer une
communauté
donc en fait l'objet lui même ne sera
peut-être pas utile tout de suite
mais la communauté autour des valeurs
qui justement la valeur de la
planification la valeur de la
coopération la valeur là
le partage d'une forme de hiérarchie de
ce qui est important en versus ce qui
l'est moins
ça c'est quelque chose qui est un sous
produit déjà réelle de ce travail en
commun
l'internaute justement de demander
comment fédérer expliquer une majorité
que la sobriété la solution donc là il
est question de du déjà d'un collectif
qui fédérait mais j'imagine comment
fédérer plus largement au delà des
cercles qui sont déjà sensibilisés
voilà je peux répondre par très
rapidement pendant que j'en cherche ses
idées mais je sais qu'il ya une
primatologue américaine qui est
protestante évangélique qui est assez
connue qui s'appelle catherine et au qui
travaille justement essayer de
sensibiliser les gens à cette question
du changement climatique depuis des
années des années il était récemment
avec leonardo dicaprio et obama un jeudi
récemment sa date de quelques années en
direct depuis la maison blanche pour
justement parler de ces sujets donc mais
elle dit en fait la chose la plus
importante et la plus simple mais la
plus importante qu'on peut faire c'est
tout simple en parler c'est à dire de
parler autour d'eux alors elle dit
autour de la dinde de thanksgiving mais
ça peut être trop de la dinde de noël en
france ou de parler
voilà je suis pas trop dingue donc je
sais pas exactement ce moment de noël
mais en tout cas voilà c'est déjà une
réponse et parlez-en autour de vous et
faites des groupes comme le disait jean
marc rejoins tout à fait nous c'est
aussi ce qu'on est en train de décider
de faire au niveau national avec arusha
on est en train de créer des groupes un
peu dans toutes les villes pour que des
gens qui partagent aussi des valeurs à
la fois donc de 2
par rapport à cette crise écologique qui
sont convaincus de cette crise
écologique et qui ont envie de se
retrouver si parce qu'ils partagent la
foi chrétienne une foi chrétienne qui
les unit et qui leur permet de trouver
un certain nombre de points communs
voilà bah c'est en s'unissant ça crée du
lien sacré sacré plein de bonnes choses
et puis ça permet de faire une
communauté et ça permet de répandre le
mot les mots autour de nous maintenant
est-ce que ça va suffire est-ce que ça
va être assez rapide c'est toujours un
petit peu la question du verre à moitié
plein ou à moitié vide ça fait quinze
ans que j'entends les mêmes discours sur
bah oui on est on est sur le point de
basculer dans un d'un changement de
paradigme parce que dans ce coup on a
l'impression qu'à plus en plus de gens
qui sont convaincus et puis il faut il
faut tempérer sa part ce que disent et
jean-marc de à mon avis avec eux tout à
fait tailler pertinemment c'est à dire
que rendement oui on en entend on et
bassines et du changement climatique
dans les médias tout le temps mais en
fait les gens
et je dirais on est aussi tous d'un
certain côté climato-sceptiques moi le
premier j'ai pas que je doute de la
science mais dans le sens où dans mon
comportement je ne suis pas non plus
exemplaire je continue à faire des
choses dont je sais pertinemment que
c'est pas voilà donc tout ça pour dire
que je les plains portance de parler
autour de soi et puis et puis si vous
priiez de prier pour que le mot passe
voilà
merci jean marc jancovici ce que vous
avez une piste de réponse sur cet enjeu
de fédérer plus largement
je peux répondre sur ce que j'ai fait
moi qui m'a semblé produire cet effet
sans geler nécessairement chercher
il ya là il ya la pédagogie sur le
problème qui paradoxalement est un
premier élément qui permet de fédérer
des gens
alors je me suis longtemps demandé
pourquoi est ce que le fait de faire des
conférences dans lesquels on explique
que ça tout va de travers est quelque
chose qui fait venir du monde et en fait
j'ai fini par me faire à l'idée que ce
que je fournissais à l'audience dans ce
genre d'intervention
c'était une remise en cohérence de trucs
qui avant
de pièces du puce de kehl et j'en
arrivais pas à rassembler et qu'en fait
le fait d'arriver à voir le tableau dans
son ensemble même s'il n'est pas rose
était quand même un élément de confort
par rapport au fait de ne rien
comprendre du tout
donc la pédagogie est quelque chose qui
permet un peu de te créer ce premier
élément de fédération après le deuxième
élément de fédérations c'est d'appeler à
l'action mais l'action les gens là
comprennent mieux quand il ya eu d'abord
la pédagogie sur le sujet à traiter donc
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu à tous
que c'est très difficile de dissocier
l'un de l'autre sinon j'ai envie de dire
on est dans le dans l'action sans
sans explication de texte de préalables
alors pardonnez moi ce gros mais on est
dans le fait religieux mais dans une
religion dont on ne sait pas si elle est
adaptée à l'époque
donc on a voilà donc
on risque de rater une marche km
engouement finira par buté sur un mur de
réalité parce que c'est pas assez pas
adapté à l'époque
voilà mais je veux mais je pour le
moment c'est ce qui modestement de mon
côté peut fonctionner c'est à la fois le
la pédagogie est un élément d'un élément
de rassemblement quand même et puis
parce que les gens sont curieux
et puis le l'incitation à l'action ou la
réflexion sur l'action
joseph si je peux aussi ajouter quelques
je sais et je sais pas jean-marc si tu
ressens ça aussi et je sais que moi
souvent dans les interventions que je
fais j'ai beaucoup de pression
des gens qui m'invitent comme je vais
manger et surtout dans intervenir dans
des églises mais j'ai beaucoup de
pression souvent de gens qui veulent que
je donne un message positif
parce que le discours que j'entends sans
fin les gens qui m'invitent souvent le
10 mai on en a marre entre guillemets
fin surtout les gens sont fatigués
d'entendre des messages négatifs sont
fatigués d'entendre des choses
angoissante ils veulent quelque chose de
positif et en fait
je me rappelle d'avoir une discussion
assez long et avec un collègue à ce
sujet il ya pas longtemps parce que ça
me ça m'agace et c c'est à dire que je
veux pas me transformer en faux
prophètes j'ai pas envie d'aller dans
les églises ou ailleurs et dire des
choses que je ne crois pas et un peu la
pression c'est de dire ben en fait on va
quand même s'en sortir typiquement en
mettant des éoliennes partout bon et
j'ai pas envie de donner ça mais surtout
ce que je me disais finalement en
préparant ce forum avec toi jean max et
je me disais qu'en fait toi tu es un
exemple que j'avais pas pensé à citer à
mon collègue un exemple inverse c'est à
dire que tu ne peux pas dire que tu
donnes un message positif je pense que
tu as l'honnêteté aussi de dire que tu
n'as pas la solution et ça c'est tu fais
un jeu je pense à ce propos introductif
à ta conférence à sciences po notamment
où tu dis ben je vous donne je suis pas
là pour vous donner des solutions j'ai
pas beaucoup parler de solution je vois
surtout vous avez toute votre vie pour
trouver des solutions et je trouve ça
honnête et je trouve que dans ton
message effectivement tu fais passer
n'est pas un message positif et
j'aurais presque dire que c'est un
message prophétique dans le sens où je
pense que tu annonces des choses depuis
15 ans qu'ils sont en train de se
réaliser déjà et puis je pense aussi que
tu es comme beaucoup de prophètes c'est
si tu me permets je sais que tu n'as pas
de barbe blanche etc mais
je pense quand même que justement
finalement tu as écouté parce que tu
n'es pas en train de dire ce que tout le
monde a envie d'en temps et que je pense
que ça ça ça paye et donc c'est un
contre exemple parce que j'entends
souvent le discours mais si seulement on
disait des choses positives les gens
nous suivraient bon je crois pas que ça
marche comme ça
merci pour conclure je propose une
dernière question une personne évoquer
la frustration face à l'inaction des
pouvoirs publics sur les questions
climatiques et c'est vrai que moi
j'observe pas mal dans ma génération et
d'autre la montée en puissance de
mouvements qu'on pourrait qualifier de
désobéissance qu'elle soit civile
non-violente violente différentes formes
quel est votre regard chacun sur ses
actions et ses groupes par exemple jean
françois moreau est ce que c'est
acceptable d'un point de vue chrétien
d'encourager à la désobéissance civile
par exemple finir monsieur jancovici dit
que c'est quelque chose aussi qui
pourrait tout à fait s'inscrire dans le
répertoire d'un shifters dans son
répertoire d'action
alors moi pour répondre rapidement j'ai
pas de problème avec les désobéissance
civile tant que ça ne cause pas de
violences aux personnes
je pense d'ailleurs que plein de
chrétiens ont utilisé la désobéissance
il dans le passé je pense à martin
luther king notamment etc etc donc ça
j'ai pas de problème le théorique là
dessus je dirais ou pratiques par contre
je suis pas sûr à titre personnel je
donc que ça soit la bonne manière de je
ne sais pas et c'est une question rungis
est pas une je n'ai pas là je ne dis pas
que je vais pas évolué sur le sujet
peut-être d'ailleurs je sais ce que je
veux dire c'est que si j'avais la
conviction que d'aliments enchaîné à un
pont par exemple pour bloquer la
circulation ou je sais pas quoi
allez faire avancer le schmiblick même
si ça me coûtait un procès ou je sais
pas quoi bon j'ai peu de chances d'aller
en prison mais ce que je sais que je
suis j'ai des amis activistes qui font
ce genre de choses
la peine de prison est quand même assez
théorique mais ceci dit si j'étais
convaincu que c'était la bonne façon je
pense que je le ferai
j'aurai le courage le jour ex2 ça je
sais pas mais je n'ai en tout cas d'un
point de vue voilà maintenant est ce que
c'est la bonne façon est-ce que ça
est-ce que ça fait vraiment avancer le
schmilblick je sais pas
je sur cette question de la
désobéissance civile je pense que ça
crée aujourd'hui des inconvénients
marginaux pour des progrès marginaux
c'est à dire que c'est pas quelque chose
qui est très bon et très bien vous
bloqué un pont dans paris
bon ça fait ça fait un peu parler du
sujet
des inconvénients pour l'ensemble de la
société d'hawaï a pas deux pareils sur
terre ensuite à paris a pas qu'un pont
[Musique]
c'est une petite gêne on va dire
l'état et c'est un petit bénéfice
[Musique]
du clan j'ai pas de problème moral avec
ça je veux dire j'ai des gens qui voient
là c'est que cette année ça n'est pas
plus de la nsa pas comment dire la gêne
occasionnée n'est ni plus ni moins
gênante quand une manifestation tout à
fait autorisé bloquent la circulation
oui la différence quoi la manifestation
était autorisée et bloquent la
circulation les gens s'enchaînèrent à
pons est pas autorisé ça bloque la
circulation
quelque part c'est celle enregistrée
très voisin pour moi
ce qui est
ce qui est dingue c'était une
manifestation de plus souvent d'une
classe d'âge parce que c'est quand même
assez rare les gens âgés j'ai
l'impression qu'ils font ce genre de
france ce genre de choses on en voit on
en voit
justement en grande bretagne il ya
beaucoup de deux pasteurs et de deux
membres du clergé qui font des actions
comme ça
âgé de 70 ans ou 80 ans mais j'ai moins
connaissance de ça en france mais en
angleterre c'est très répondu d'accord
j'étais biaisé alors par mon
montfranc aux centristes
voilà je ne pense pas que c'est la clé
du problème enfin que c'est exactement
que ce soit la clé de la solution
la petite personnel j'ai rien contre
mais je pense que ça restera un air de
malheureusement quelque chose de plus de
plus marginal ce qui est si je peux
conclure sur la façon dont le monde
politique se met en route pour ce que
j'en connais le monde politique se met
rarement en route sur la seule base d'un
constat que les choses ne vont pas
si on veut que le monde politique se met
en route il faut lui amener le constat
il faut lui amener la solution et il
faut le garder le pouvoir de nuisance si
la solution n'est pas mise en avant il
faut ces trois éléments la désobéissance
civile aujourd'hui relève du fait que ça
ne va pas
ça n'est pas suffisant pour que le
pouvoir politique se met en route dans
la bonne direction
si on lui avait d'une construction sans
élément déclencheur ou sans pouvoir de
nuisance donc c'est la discussion qu'on
a longuement lui tout à l'heure sur le
pdf ça ne suffit pas non plus voilà ce
qu'il faut avec c'est un déclencheur ou
un pouvoir de nuisance c'est le
troisième élément qui manque est là
aussi pour embrayer sur quelque chose
qui a été si c'était une plaisanterie ou
sérieux de la part de jean-françois tout
à l'heure mais le fait que alors que
j'ai lu est strictement rien demandé la
presse répète à l'envi que je serai
ministrable
c'est quelque chose qui accroît sans que
je n'ai rien fait pour ça mon pouvoir de
nuisance
parce que ça veut dire que j'acquière
aux yeux des médias
un rôle de personnes dont
comment dire le jugement négatif sur la
politique publique
est relayée donc touche du monde donc
enquiquine le pouvoir en place donc ça
ça ça c'est un élément qui me sert si
j'ai l'intention d'essayer de pousser
des constructions qui ont été faites par
ailleurs mais il faut les 3 il faut le
constat que ça va pas bien il faut la
construction qui répond et il faut une
forme d'éléments de pression ils
amassent peut être un élément de
pression et donc on finir par où on a
commencé je leur dis si l'église
s'empare de la question des limites
planétaires
et je vais quand même me permettre une
taquinerie il ya des sujets sur lesquels
elle a encore du chemin à faire
et bien c'est quelque chose qui ne peut
qu'y vakili rad nécessairement dans ce
qui contribuera à ce que les choses
aillent dans le bon sens
merci je vous propose de conclure ici
peut-être dès ce que jean froissart vous
vouliez dire un dernier mot et
je pense juste que ce que je peux je
peux répéter c'est à dire que pour moi
le désir de sobriété passe par un
changement de paradigme de la société
qui dans mon sens ce sera très difficile
à réaliser si on exclut
le la dimension spirituelle puisque
aujourd'hui la société matérialiste à
peu de chose à offrir à quelqu'un qui
voudrait finalement se serrer la
ceinture
et donc je pense que pour moi
effectivement l'église au sens église
universelle sans chapelle particulière
les l'église peut jouer un rôle vraiment
majeur dans cette transition écologique
et évidemment c'est ce à quoi je
travaille avec l'association arusha
français avec d'autres partenaires
donc merci fabien merci pour cette
conclusion
avant de nous quitter
je vais faire défiler quelques annonces
alors tout d'abord un court
questionnaire de satisfaction nous
permettrait d'avoir vos retours cher
participants participantes à cette
soirée
afin qu'on puisse s'améliorer donc le
lien va normalement ce se glisser dans
le jazz vous pouvez aussi placer le code
qui s'affiche à l'écran
donc voilà je vous laisse le temps de le
faire quelques secondes
il ya également une question qui a été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises dans le chat
c'est celle du replay donc ce forum sera
bien disponible en replay ainsi que tous
les autres sur la présente chaîne
youtube du forum veritas france que le
lien va également être glissée dans le
chatt n'hésitez pas par ailleurs à vous
abonner à cette chaîne
et je vous annonce d'ailleurs dès à
présent que deux prochains débats sont
prévus l'an premier dans deux semaines
le lundi 16 mai 2022 à 19h30 toujours
sur le thème est il rationnel de croire
en dieu c'est peut-être une question que
certains se posent j'ai vu une petite
réaction dans le sens des amis
imaginaires
est-ce que c'est rationnel de croire en
dieu cette année imaginaire alors ce
sera une question qu'on pourra poser à
deux philosophes l'un chrétien et
l'autre à thé donc lundi 16 mai et puis
dans un sujet un peu plus proche de
celui d'aujourd'hui
sur la question crise écologique qu'elle
salue pour notre planète nous
accueillerons cette fois deux chrétiens
donc toujours vous jean françois moureau
mais aussi l'économiste jésuites qu'elle
giro donc ne ratez pas ça ce sera le 20
juin à 19h30
enfin vous pouvez retrouver les
actualités des groupes bibliques
universitaire pouvoir trouver un gpu
local si vous êtes intéressé grâce au
site gb eut point fr est également la
page facebook du gpu pons même chose si
vous souhaitez avoir des informations
sur arusha l'association dont jean
françois moreau et de directeur donc le
site internet arusha point fr également
les réseaux sociaux facebook instagram
linkedin
voilà un grand merci à vous deux à nos
invités pour la qualité de leurs
interventions
merci à toutes celles et ceux qui ont
permis à cet événement d'avoir lieu et
merci vous qui l'avez suivi de chez vous
en grand nombre voilà on espère qu'il
participera à son échelle à la prise de
conscience des défis climatiques et
énergétiques qui sont devant nous belle
soirée
bonsoir